listen uh it is uh New Year's Eve and of
course all the new shows are doing those
reviews of the Year isn't everyone so
festive
yes that lady hasn't taken her hat
off at any minute she can leave yeah
I'll see how the show goes yeah I've got
some chestnuts to sell this thing better
not be a dud cuz I am out of
here it might have been a Christmas gift
and she just wants to get it on
television
they're doing the kind of those New
Year's reviews so we thought we might
ask our audience right for the
highlights of their year and then we
could throw back to you guys who could
do them like news headlines oh okay so
for so so Christina what was the
highlight of your year oh gosh um not
getting
shingles okay that didn't happen um I
don't know uh you know watching my uh
daughters
sing Jingle Bells over and over again
okay and then the headline would be
actress pretends not to be bored by
child or uh or something maybe oh oh we
got more got more I was thinking hello
Jingles goodbye
[Applause]
shingles yeah sounding
all right I'm going to go I'm going to
go into the crowd now and see and see
see what's happened to people so uh
start the man oh look you your Christmas
jumper H now I'm sensing this man has
had a fascinating
year what's his
name sorry it's a Danish name oh
marvelous Danish name Scandinavia is
represented tonight so it's lovely old
older old old I only old older old
AA OA OA OA oh like Irish for Apple okay
OA what's been the highlight of your
year AA what have you my highight of my
year yeah
yeah not much is happening no let's go
to let's go back to will in The
Newsroom o o
o has no memory of
2013 let me do let me do this lady here
hello hi what what's your name Kate Kate
lovely and what's what's been the big
event in your year Kate um I actually
got over my phobia of
eggs were you working with a
therapist there was alcohol involved so
you got drunken at an
egg okay let's go to The Newsroom where
Steve will report on Kate getting over
her fur of
eggs young woman named Kate is beautiful
and I am getting a
divorce now I think all the work went
into the face not so much into the
outfit it does like it's him on audition
off day yeah it's like care in the
community
really Zachary here is Lady
Gaga can you see
yes Wonder
happy